okay so uh we're on page uh
one one four and one one five now
okay taina hanker with marota dori
footwork
this may seem uh a very short
piece because it's uh
but
if you've got the time hang correct you
know that's
all the pieces correct they hold you
but
as we shift the weight turn the front
foot
now this one
you
you float
i've made other films with the ken
and showing you how
how you float the foot from side to side
we do the weapons
to improve our targets so
this is the only reason we do the
weapons right
timing well timing fear panic
overcoming so many things but but uh
it's uh to improve our target soon
so if we
move like this
a slightly outward foot is okay now
because
it
might be here having a firm
a firm feeling with your hips
so foot straight or slightly turned
turn anchor the person holds you
you turn
here
turn the hinker with my rotate dory
footwork
you turn
instead of coming back here
you adjust
so tana hanko
here
my rotate dory footwork
so this is a little more interesting
on these two pages
bring it to your
center
fix it
not this side of your central line
but
this side of your center line
turn the fingers upright
bring the thumb in don't leave the thumb
out
so that you've got this cup
the other side of your breast line
so it's used to say keep that side the
breast button not this side
this is for basic and also if you want
to throw them
so the tana hinka
shift to the center
footwork
now
as you turn from here
if the hands
on the wrong side of the breastbone when
you turn it will feel like a pull and if
they're
even if they're moving and they anchor
their self they'll put they'll put you
and stop you
moving this hand afterwards so the hand
has to be located in the middle
show you from this handle
so go
to that place
when you're about here
let's say this is this is 12 o'clock
i'm at 10 o'clock with my center as i
now
turn
like this and i dig in
you should hear if it's not too noisy
you should hear their back foot
as they come round
as you take that extra little step that
usually makes their back foot do this
if
if they only do that you haven't got it
correct
okay so they're holding
and all of a sudden it
it makes that happen
so
down there
about here you're gonna as you do that
that's when you hear that back foot move
boom
that last
that last piece
if their back foot moved
it needs to move or as you can't do the
miroti dory throw
if their back foot's in the way
you can't get behind them because they
didn't move they're in your way
so
so you've done that
they're in your way you would never be
able to throw them with all of this
their back foot moves that means their
angle their body moves
the angle now
is if i
had the joe
that they're the angle of the joe and
i'm the angle of the joe so i now
step in the angle of the joe
i bring this up
via this side of the breastbone
and now when i get to here
i lift this under their chin because
they're light they can't dig into that
they're light i push the front leg the
same as my rotary door turn the hips
finish the same
okay
so
with you
okay
this is this side of the breastbone not
this side
they've moved to the angle of the joe
i'm at the angle of the joe the distance
is the same
i step behind them straighten the leg
turn the hips you know this all works
like a little machine
one
as it's about to end
turn as it's about to end
all right
sorry i've got that wrong
talking
right so here
straighten it come up
you're coming up all the time right
up
ah
okay do you notice how this
rolls over
rolls over but i was over
well of course it's all one it's not
staggered like that this is for your
one-to-one personal practice like i'm
doing here
dynamic
they should fall in an exact
line this way
so
if my body was a
if my body was a straight joe
they would be the t
they would
they would be on top of the
straight joe
that would be a t angle
if they fall
to the side
like that it means i use too much
shoulders
okay so if you throw them too much you
didn't think you should throw them as
your shoulders but if you do they'll end
up around there
that way they should
fall
straight under your
your wrists
there
okay
i don't feel as though if that was one
of my best even though i should
shouldn't say that should i really
in the teacher but i am still a student
it's very difficult that one but it's
also very beautiful and really enjoyable
once you get it all the pieces correct
so please um
please work
yeah
what do you full arms full
there's a wonderful statue of o'sensei i
think in a place called tanby of him
doing that bomb statue
okay
until the next time
we'll carry on
and the next time
so these were the pages um
one one four one one five
okay
try not to rush
try to
work it out
try everything you can if you can have
the advantage of a partner
you know
self-practice is always a wonderful
thing we perhaps don't do enough of it
because we think we need to be on the
mat we think we need a partner that's
not always the case
you know you can work all these shapes
out
you might criticize yourself to have
yourself off but you know
this will be
you'll know
when it feels good or not
and yes it might not work when you get
on the map with a partner at least
you've
you know you've worked it out and what
if it doesn't work with a partner then
you've missed something out and you've
got to go back to study you might have
tried entering in on the variety diary
rather than
you know drop it out before you enter
before you went like this you might have
needed to
soften it
draw draw on it more
you know a ton of hanger you might have
gone into them rather than
you know
rather than leave it there you might
have sort of moved it that way as you
went to go in so rather than go to that
make making sure it's the other side
adjust the foot
adjust both feet and just do things what
need doing
step
roll i always fix the fingers i don't
know whatever
perhaps since he told me i fixed the
fingers to my key
so i've got a pivot something to press
against
to pivot this movement
is what's going to unbalance them
to get their
their body back on its own pulling it
off won't work you've got to bring it up
and roll it fully
bring it up roll it fully
donald hello